K
MUCKING THESE HOMES OUT.
>> Tucker: FOOD PRICE, IF YOU'VE
BEEN TO THE GROCERY STORE, YOU
KNOW ARE CONTINUING TO CLIMB.
POLITICAL LEADERS LIKE JOE BIDEN
AND ELIZABETH WARREN SAY IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE WAR IN
UKRAINE, BUT GREEDY GROCERS WHO
ARE GETTING RICH.
WE NEVER SPEAK TO CEOs,
BECAUSE THEY NEVER COME ON, BUT
ONE JOINS US TONE.
BOB, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON TONIGHT.
SO YOU HAVE HEARD, YOU RUN THIS
HUGE COMPANY, AND YOU'VE HEARD
THAT YOU'RE THE REASON THAT FOOD
PRICES ARE UP.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> NOT TRUE, TUCKER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE IN
SPEAKING THE TRUTH.
AID LIKE TO SAY OUR HEARTS, OUR
PRAYERS, AND OUR HELP, BECAUSE
WE ARE IN PUERTO RICO AND
FLORIDA, GO OUT TO THE VICTIMS
OF FIONA AND IAN.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> AT THE CORE OF INFLATION, AND
IT'S OUT OF CONTROL, ESPECIALLY
IN FOOD, IS EVIL.
OUR DESIRE TO CONTROL US.
WHEN I WAS A CHILD, MY PARENTS
SAID, NEVER TAKE CANDY FROM A
STRANGER.
THEY'RE GIVING OUT CANDY,
INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE NOT TO
WORK.
THEY'RE TAKING AWAY OUR PURPOSE,
OUR SPIRIT, OUR REASON TO GET UP
EVERY DAY.
THEY'RE DOING IT WITHOUT THEIR
OWN CANDY.
THEY'RE TAKING OUR CANDY, AND
USING IT TO INCENTIVIZE US NOT
TO, WOULD.
THAT'S VERY INFLATIONARY.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU'RE THE
ONLY PERSON I'VE HEARD SAY THAT,
THAT THIS IS AN INTENTIONAL
EFFORT TO TAKE PEOPLE'S PURPOSE
FOR LIVING AWAY, WHICH IS WORK,
THE ACT OF CREATION.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ALIVE.
WHY DOES NOBODY SAY THAT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE WERE AN
ESSENTIAL BUSINESS, TUCKER.
WE NEVER STOPPED WORKING.
WORK IS ESSENTIAL.
IT GIVES US OUR REASON.
YOU KNOW, GOD -- I LOVE THIS GAL
FROM ITALY, THE FASCIST SPEAK,
GOD, FAMILY, COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, YOU NEED TO HAVE A
PURPOSE.
SHE SAYS WE ALL HAVE OUR GENETIC
CODE.
EACH ONE OF US IS MADE IN THE
LIKENESS OFFED FOR WITH OUR OWN
IDENTITY.
WE ALL HAVE A PURPOSE.
NOW, YOU TAKE THAT PURPOSE AWAY
BY THE VERY FEW WHO WANT TO OWN
US AND SLAVE US, CONTROL US, FOR
THEIR OWN GREED AND POWER.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER HEARD A
CEO OF A BIG COMPANY TALK THAT
WAY.
I HOPE YOU DON'T MIND IF WE
BOTHER YOU TO COME DOWN AND SEE
YO